it is malpractice yeah to put that boy
in a dress change his name to Emily and
then prepare to cut off his balls
full disclosure before before this
segment I spoke about I haven't been
feeling that well now I didn't know that
he was still a practicing doctor because
most of our friends who are doctors in
the show true they have abandoned a long
time ago and they're not the best
references right they host like American
Ninja Warrior yeah or they write books
they just say to use the hot water and
soap for everything exactly pretty much
yeah well this next guess he still still
is a doctor and has written some
fantastic books let me make sure I get
them out for their four books why gender
matters the collapse of parenting boys
adrift and girls on the edge you can
follow me on twitter at unfragmented sex
thanks for being here sir thanks for
riding bay well I'm really glad to have
you listen that that that voice is there
something about the doctors voice where
you have to have a low soothing tone do
they teach you that I wanted to be a
radio announcer I auditioned this is w w
DB Boston's talk radio and they turned
me down so you just said I just go be a
doctor instead yeah that was my Safety's
Harvard so you know your timing couldn't
be better
obviously we do this change my mind
segment on the show well I shouldn't say
obviously you're probably not familiar
most most people don't watch a show so
that's totally fine we do a segment
called change my mind where I'll just
talk with people on the street for hours
unedited and it's done pretty well you
don't know tens of millions of people
have been watching them it's resonated
because it's the opposite of cable news
where it's just a conversation more
similar to what you would have in real
life the most recent one was there are
only two genders changed my mind and oh
my goodness doctor I mean you would have
thought that I brought a copy of mine
comes out there and slapped it on the
table you've been writing about this for
a long time can you tell us a little bit
about the progression as to how we've
gotten to this point maybe and where do
you think it started this blurring
elimination of gender this confusion
absolutely you know in 1994 the American
Psychiatric Association said that they
estimated that about one in 30,000
adults is transgender but they said it's
so rare
that they really can't come up with any
any good numbers last year Time magazine
had a cover story beyond he or she and
they had a survey of 2000 Millennials
and they said are you
cisgender or not and 12% one in eight
said that they were not suspender IE
they're transgender so we went from less
than 1 in 10,000 to more than 1 in 10 in
30 years well that's crazy okay that
that can't be right yeah that polling
that polling must be skewed I would
imagine because I don't know well that
that's an outlier but even legitimate
researchers are now claiming that 1% 2%
of young adults are transgender which
again is a hundredfold increase in
20-some years and I've talked to my
colleagues because you know I started a
practice from scratch and just outside
Washington DC grew it to 7,000 patients
I knew every one of my patients well and
we have many gay men let many lesbian
women we did not have a single trans
individual in those 7,000 patients and
these people confided in me right I knew
their secrets that their partners did
not know and I've reached out to others
now there's a lot of confusion going on
here my friend and colleague Larry
Cahill at University of California
Irvine says okay male and female may not
be binary but they are bimodal they are
bimodal meaning more than ninety-nine
point eight percent of the human race is
either male or female right some very
rare conditions that we call intersex
conditions where a human may actually
have both an ovary and a testicle that
happens right but you add up all those
conditions and I wrote a scholarly paper
on that entitled how Tom and his
intersex this reason just recent changed
my mind
self-proclaimed intersex girl sat down
and said it was you know at least one
point seven percent of the population is
intersex she's probably higher if
doctors didn't play God in a sign gender
at birth I know that's inaccurate that's
love for you that it's not it is not
accurate she's quoting a surgeon made by
Anne fausto-sterling a professor Brown
an in Miami Jew and deconstruct her
claim and show it is not science it is
ideology that when you add up true
intersex conditions the highest possible
estimate is two and ten thousand so the
claim of one point seven percent or two
percent it is a / s factor of 100 and it
matters because two and ten thousand
that's a rare anomaly well then why is
my and I think you get into that a lot
as to why gender matters and you talk
about particularly young men quite a bit
the difference between boys and girls
but here's the immediate follow-up that
we can't do in the change my mind but
I'd love to ask you as a doctor why why
are these people who who are being cited
why are they pushing the idea of vastly
higher numbers of intersex and
transgenders than actually exist what's
the motivation there's a war on male and
female and the war is driven by
confusion and by a misplaced
understanding of social justice I
understand where they're coming from for
two thousand years or more more actually
we've had men saying that hey men and
women are different and that means will
men are less capable in the marketplace
and women should be at home barefoot
pregnant and in the kitchen we've got
more than two thousand years of history
of men using claims about difference
between male and female to justify
limiting opportunity for women I get
that and so many of these modern social
justice warriors feel that hey the only
virtuous thing is to deny that there's
any differences that's the only way
forward the only way we're going to
ensure equal opportunity for women is to
insist that male and female are social
constructs people invent
they can create them they can change
them any way they like and that might
fit a certain social justice warrior
kind of worldview but it happens to be
false it's not true right in my book why
gender matters I lay out the research I
have more than 400 scholarly references
showing dramatic profound hard-wired
differences in how men and women hear
see and smell which are not just in our
species they're in every species that
people have looked at right these
different so now what's what for many
times there's someone like you who
focuses on this because it's the
accusations of hate speech right now it
seems as though even psychology you look
at the DSM dsm-5 you look at the way
terminology changes it seems as though a
social agenda is is driving in many ways
science and medicine not the other way
around and that for someone like me
listen who's a layman I can't keep up
with all of the modern medical
advancements right it's it's it's not my
job we've had doctors in the show who go
I can't make sense of it but how how do
we keep up with this and why is it
happen that is so concerning to me that
a social agenda would drive medicine or
science well that was a big motivation
for me to write my why gender matters 14
years ago and the revised edition last
year because so much has changed yes you
know 20 years I know 40 years ago if a
girl wanted to roll in the mud and
wrestle a hog that was fine now the
parents were asked you know maybe your
daughter is trans you know have you
thought about transitioning her to the
male role this is psychotic and I mean
that quite literally it is deranged it
is detached from reality there's all
different ways to be a girl there's all
different ways to be a boy and the
ironic result of these social justice
warriors is that they are ironically
creating stereotypes yes a girl who
doesn't want to play with dolls well she
must be trans no she's not trans and you
know it's a girl there's more than one
way to be a girl in figures under men
Caitlyn Jenner is a walking Barbie doll
right feminists would be furious if
anyone else were on the cover of these
magazines like
it's a guy so the giant to fake boobs
and the perfect makeup but not in the
corset we're fine with homeless and my
producer had a question for some news I
noticed with many of the transgenders
we've interviewed be it on the show or
in these change my mind segments almost
all of them have been transitioned for
like maybe a year maybe two years it's
all very recent thing in the end they
like to pretend they've known all along
that you've been denying the truth and
that transgenders have existed
throughout every every century is it are
there statistics reflect that we don't
know a lot about this we've got lots of
good studies we've got people like dr.
Kenneth hooker who's been studying kids
for 30 years so 30 years ago a five year
old boy is brought into his office and
the five-year-old boy says I know I'm a
girl trapped in the body of a boy I'm a
girl right what do we know about these
four individuals we know a lot about
them because dr. Zook has followed
thousands of these kids for 30 years and
we know the great majority of those
five-year-old boys who had aged 5 say
I'm a girl trapped in the body of a boy
20 years down the road that individual
most likely will be a gay man he doesn't
want to be a woman he doesn't think he
is a woman he didn't understand look
figuring out that you're gay takes time
if you ask a five-year-old would you
like to be sexually intimate with a man
or a woman they don't know what that
means nor should they so when I looked a
fan put him on puberty blockers doctor
that's that's a fry I asked my mom if I
get when I was seven years old I asked
my mom if I marry a woman do I have to
take all my you have to take off my
pajamas in bed and my mom said yes you
do but you'll want to I said yuck
but asking seven year-olds who they want
to be intimate with sexually is not
appropriate it's not meaningful that
five-year-old has no way of knowing
whether he's going to grow to be a gay
man a straight man what have you it is
malpractice yeah to put that boy in a
dress change his name to Emily and then
prepare to cut off his balls very
sophisticated here
I I booked why gender matters new
addition as a whole chapter on
transgender which wasn't in the older
edition because I'm trying to give that
parent guidance if your five-year-old
son comes to you and says I'm a girl
what should you do well you don't have
to guess we've got good research from
good scientists who've been studying
this for 30 years
don't listen that Caitlyn Jenner or
MSNBC look at what the researchers have
published on this point it's readily
available I provide the links find
someone who's knowledgeable you know get
some guidance that's it it's very good
of don't let people start medicating
your child don't let surgeons come
anywhere close to your child I you know
that's that's a great question that you
bring up and I would love to have you
back I know we don't have a ton of time
today but I'd love that be back for a
long-form interview just to dissect this
because we've talked about this in the
show it is asinine to me to argue that a
child should be able to transition
before we reached the age of consent so
I can only consent sexually at 16 but
I'm going to make a decision that
permanently affects my sexual well-being
and my sexual lifestyle by the time I'm
8 because Chaz Jennings had a show and
did jazz hands I do so I do want to have
you back and speak about this at length
if you can the books are chipped why
gender matters there's a new edition
collapse of parenting boys adrift and
girls on the edge you can follow dr.
Leonard sex at unfried you'll kids
doctor can we have you back for a full
45 minutes to an hour sometimes few
weeks absolutely
if you like this video subscribe hit the
notification bell or if you want to
continue to enjoy free content support
us at ladder with credit.com /mo club
where you get the full nightly show an
hour every day free along with all of
our friends content if not you don't
want to do any of those things you're
probably just here you're watching me
seething you came here to hate watch
that being said the internet was created
for people like you